je pense que c'est très compliqué de
savoir ce qui se passe en effet sur ces
données euh une fois qu'elles sont
localisées sur un certain serveur je
sais que malgré le fait que les les
serveurs enfin que les
utilisateurs des les données des
utilisateurs américains sont désormais
stockés aussi aux États-Unis il y a
toujours des backup en Chine notamment à
Shanghai
je
j'ai du mal à imaginer comment ils
puissent ne pas y avoir de perméabilité
sur l'accès aux données même étant donné
qu'on a des données d'utilisateur
stockés en Europe aux États-Unis
notamment parce que Tik Tok aura besoin
de ces données pour continuer à
entraîner son algorithme et que
l'algorithme est développé en Chine et
que du coup ils vont avoir un moment
besoin de faire accès afin de faire des
requêtes à ces données alors peut-être
qu'elles sont anonymisées ça va être des
données on n'aura pas forcément le
numéro de téléphone associé mais il faut
aussi garder en tête que ce sont des
données qui sont tellement précis es et
spécifiques que c'est des données qui
sont des anonymnisables assez facilement
on a en fait qu'un seul utilisateur qui
correspond à un certain profil d'intérêt
et de comportement et une adresse IP et
toutes ces choses là donc en fait même
les données anonymisées le sont jamais
vraiment et j'ai du mal à concevoir
comment Tik Tok pourrait se passer
complètement de faire accès d'accéder à
ces données